what's the alternative given that they
have a point well as far as I can tell
the alternative is a proper return to
the past and that is precisely to
journey into the chaos to look at the
worst possible thing and to pull the
dead farther out from the chaotic depths
that's how you start being a puppet
someone whose strings are being pulled
by forces they do not understand behind
the scenes you find out what's great
about your culture this thing that's
provided us with everything that we see
in this room this amazing warmth that
we're experiencing when it's 30 bloody
below outside the fact that the
electricity or the horn and that
computational resources are working that
we can all sit here peacefully and then
no one is hungry fact were too fat
that's are a big problem oh no we have
so much stuff for getting fat yeah well
that's a good problem to have we should
have some gratitude
for what's being produced that's brought
us to this point and we need to wake up
and understand what we're doing well
that's what that's what people like
that's what the psychoanalysts were
trying to do in the 20th century that's
what all the great clinicians were
trying to do and I would say above all
else that was what Carl Jung was trying
to do
he believed firmly that the idea of the
divine spark within the individual was a
was a metaphysical reality by which he
meant a reality that actually
transcended and and and existed
superordinate to the physical reality a
more real reality that's whatever
consciousness is something we understand
from a scientific perspective not at all
that's been represented in our
mythologies as far back as we can push
them as an independent agent in the
world giving rise to form that's how we
treat each other that's how we recognize
ourselves that's how we judge each other
you make your bed and then you lie in it
and everyone knows it and that's not to
say that you're not subject to random
and chaotic circumstances and the
tragedy of life just because you can do
some things doesn't mean you can do
everything but you can do some things
and if you don't do them then things
fall apart
and the problem with things falling
apart is that you will be happy about it
to the degree that you're not trying to
repair them because to the degree that
you do not manifest what's within you
then your life falls apart around you
and everything that could make you
better multiplies until you're in a
situation where you want the destruction
you want to bring it on and it's not
surprising because life can be so
terrible that the question of whether or
not it should exist at all can be a real
question but the answer to that is is
life so terrible that it shouldn't exist
well the answer is it depends on how you
live it and if your life is so terrible
that you can't bear it then it raises
the question of whether or not you're
living it properly and that's not to say
that people don't suffer under burdens
that are too great for them to bear they
certainly do it doesn't matter because
if you let that embedder you if you let
that destroy your allegiance to the
proper path all it does is make that
worse and everything else it's no out